welcome to GameSpot gameplay so what
happens when you drop a Formula One race
car from altitude or when you transform
into a boat in the middle of a city's
financial district in the crew to
switching between anything with wheels
wings or an outboard motor is fair game
even in inappropriate places we know
especially in inappropriate places
here's the gamescom co-op demo showing
off the seamless switch between free
roam and activities in the open world
please pardon the chat audio since we
had devs chiming in during our co-op
session
are you a closeted wild run fan or
addicted to steep is this the child of
those two games you were looking for
let's discuss it in the comments below
and while you're here feel free to give
us a like or subscribe to our channel so
we can let you know when videos drop for
other upcoming driving games like Forza
Motorsport 7 and Gran Turismo sport
thanks for watching
looks like there
we sell drinks that are easier to do
I know off that jump it was like
because it was like
you can kind of hold it
Oh
it won't let you
area
[Music]
yeah
they surprised
[Music]
Oh
it wants you to like be a fact thank you
[Applause]
but it up on enough
but I got it
[Music]
and they still have all the common
theory gonna Stoke you look like the
wilderun
[Music]
if I
like the monaco stall
look at altar
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Thank You coach really good
[Music]
right yeah
[Music]
you